[Music]
in London Ontario There lives a man
whose basement is unlike anything you've
ever seen
this is Robert wardoff hi my name is
Robert wardoff Robert has been playing
the same Dungeons and Dragons campaign
for over 30 years 35 years to be exact
I'm sorry that's okay
welcome would you like to play a Dwarven
Rogue you look like a rogue wait let's
back up for a second Dungeons and
Dragons is a fantasy role-playing game
where a group of people come together
and play out Adventures dictated by a
dungeon master these adventures also
known as campaigns are set in the
Dungeons and Dragons World and normally
have an end point or they just fizzle
out due to people's lack of commitment
but Robert is in a league of his own and
here's why
the dude has a serious collection I
think our collection of Miniatures is
around twenty thousand and then over the
years I discovered terrain ultimately
I'm a collector also and a lot of my
enjoyment comes from being able to get
new stuff and to put new stuff on the
table so the players are constantly
coming across new settings
because it's a game that doesn't stick
to one particular campaign setting I'm
able to use any figs that actually fit
the world and so it is a long process
but over 35 years you can develop quite
a collection as Robert's collection grew
so did the number of players word began
to spread about the never-ending
campaign we have people coming from all
over the country to play often flying in
wait all over the country that's right
Robert can we play now
these are some of the people who play in
Robert's game where are you guys from
I flew in from Saskatoon Saskatchewan I
drove in from Toronto Brussels Ontario
camoco Ontario Calgary Alberta hold on
what happens if people can't fly in or
drive to Robert's house to play
[Music]
solved
[Music]
the game has always been determined
really through friendship it's really
been a way that I keep my friends
together I knew early on that if I was
able to create a game that was good
enough and that means it had to be
better than video games it had to be
better than any other game they could
find that they would keep coming no
matter where I was and so that takes
again imagination and it takes change
and it takes having a system that is
constantly Dynamic that is changing that
is growing and that is constantly
getting better
foreign
[Music]